president selinski You Came Here Wanting
a time frame for membership you'll be
leaving with warm words as well as more
weapons and new security guarantees
have the Allies done enough to show
their support or do you still think that
their position on Ukraine joining NATO
is absurd and most crucially might this
lack of an invitation undermine the
morale of your forces fighting right now
on the front line and um Mr Secretary
General the Kremlin has just said it
would be the Kremlin has just said it's
a dangerous mistake for the West to give
security guarantees to Ukraine are you
worried that the Allies are taking a
step closer towards direct war with
Russia
foreign
thank you for the question
as for the invitation
I truly understand that this is a
technical signal
but
foreign
if we're not only dealing with Technics
and bureaucracy but should we look at
that as a serious factor to contribute
the motivation to the Ukrainian Society
than for me as a president that was a an
important moment I kind of compared this
fact with the candidacy for the
membership in the European Union and
um and with the dialect with other
countries I give the following example I
told that EU candidacy was just as the
signal the candidacy means no membership
but it brings a significant mobilization
for Ukraine and a powerful signal for
Russia that Ukraine is not a member of
any type of Alliance but Ukraine is
willing to become a member of the
European Union and will be an
independent state as for the invitation
today to this is just the same it's a
signal foreign
I can see another important signal that
I've already mentioned and we can have
some specifics about this the specifics
now if today they G7 will agree to the
first uh Declaration on security
guarantees that would be a very specific
fact because the security guarantees
says that these guarantees will be valid
on our way to Nato this is very
important this is going to be a very
specific signal as for the rest of the
points the Secretary General has already
mentioned as referred to it Alliance
thank you
and there is no risk-free option no
risk-free option for NATO allies either
but the biggest risk is if President
Putin wins because then the message is
that when he used military force when he
violates international law when invade
the neighbor then he gets what he went
what he wants and that's exactly why it
is so important for NATO allies to
support Ukraine uh because we will it
will be a tragedy for Ukraine if
President Putin wins but it will be
dangerous for us
it will make us more vulnerable
and that's also the reason why we have
been so very clear on the following that
Ukraine of course has the right to
choose his own path and what kind of
security Arrangements you want to be
part of that's the first line in the
paragraph you agree today on membership
for Ukraine and the path forward
and this is a fundamental right for
every nation
and therefore we can never allow that
Moscow starts to decide who can or who
cannot be a member of a NATO
Russia has been against ambient
enlargement of NATO
it's for NATO allies and for Ukraine to
decide
when to become a member Moscow doesn't
have a deed on that
so we are moving uh Ukraine closer to
membership we make all the the decisions
today which is the strongest the most
United message on the path towards
membership NATO has ever issued to
Ukraine and of course you do that
knowing that Moscow will protest as they
did when Finland joined or when Sweden
is joining or North Macedonia or all new
allies so so Ukraine has the right to
choose some path allies will decide it's
not for much good to decide
that what is very important about the
council that it's not instrument of
participation that is written there that
is the instrument of integration and us
also give us such spirit that will be
NATO